breaking news just this hour fox news
alert we are following two major
breaking news stories tonight the
Russian scandal continues to blow up in
the Democrats and the media's faces it
is what we have been predicting what
happened for over a year and tonight the
huge breaking news the Department of
Justice is now going to allow that FBI
informant one of the key players in the
Russian nuclear bribery plot surrounding
the uranium one scandal he will now that
gag order will be lifted that NDA lifted
and he can testify before Congress now
in just a few minutes we will speak with
the FBI informants lawyer also tonight
President Trump is calling the corrupt
uranium one deal you know that the
Clintons used to line their pockets with
millions and the Obama administration
they did nothing to stop it he called it
a modern-day Watergate we're gonna have
all the stunning brand-new details in
this uranium one scandal plus massive
fallout over the explosive revelations
that Hillary Clinton and the DNC they
are the ones that bankrolled that phony
research the salacious research fake
news dossier against Trump
now tonight Hillary Clinton the DNC they
are in serious legal trouble we'll
explain and Hillary Clinton's own former
spokesman is saying that she may have
known about the funding of this Russia
propaganda hit piece and lying to the
American people to influence an election
sound familiar plus according to two
reporters Clinton's team lied about
their involvement for over a year and
tonight we're putting you in the
lamestream media
that's right liberals on notice and
we're going to expose your hypocrisy and
your massive lies all of that in
tonight's breaking news opening
monologue
[Music]
all right in the last 48 hours we have
been making tremendous and unbelievable
progress and we want to tell you all
about it things you will only hear
tonight on Hannity breaking new
information in the unbelievable uranium
one scandal here's the truth the media
has been wrong about Trump Russia
collusion completely wrong for over a
year now we have been uncovering with
the help of the hills John Solomon circa
news.com Sarah Carter the real Russia
story now we have been right all along
everyone else in the media and the
Democrats they have been flat-out lying
to you we have another example of that
with tonight's breaking news
finally the Department of Justice we
were calling for this last night on the
program they will now allow the FBI
informant who has the documents and the
emails and the evidence that he had in
2009 that NDA is going to be lifted he
will now be allowed to testify before
Congress the Department of Justice
released a statement this evening it
reads quote as of tonight the Department
of Justice has authorized the informant
to disclose to the chairman and ranking
members on the Senate Committee on the
judiciary the House Committee on
Oversight and Government Reform and the
house permanent Select Committee on
Intelligence as well as one member of
each of their staffs any information or
documents he has concerning alleged
corruption bribery involving transaction
in the uranium market this is huge now
before this news broke tonight earlier
today the president he weighed in on the
uranium one deal of course that's the
deal why would anybody in this country a
leader in this country ever think it's a
good idea to give to the hostile entity
known as Russia and Vladimir Putin 20%
of America's uranium why would they ever
do that here's the president from
earlier today
I think the uranium sale to Russia and
the way it was done so underhanded
tremendous amounts of money being passed
I actually think that's Watergate modern
age okay I not only agree with the
president but I'll take it a step
further America's national security was
sold out
it was compromised and as we have been
saying uranium one this will be one of
the biggest scandals in American history
involving a foreign country now it's
already happening right before our very
eyes the Senate Judiciary Committee
Chairman Senator Chuck Grassley he
rightly tonight is calling for a special
council to be appointed to investigate
the corrupt crooked uranium 1 deal all
of the evidence all the facts all the
information we have been exposing and
sharing with you night after night will
no longer be ignored not only will it be
investigated if people broke the law and
I believe they did they will need to go
to jail the media is just barely and
clearly reluctantly only now starting to
cover this story here's a perfect
example Rachel Maddow and her cult of
viewers over at MSNBC conspiracy TV they
had former attorney General Eric Holder
on the show on Monday she didn't ask him
a single question about uranium one and
Maddow has probably been one of the
biggest proponents of pushing the false
narrative lies about Trump Russia
collusion Eric Holder was overseeing the
FBI as the head of the Department of
Justice as the AG he was one of the
voting members of that committee that
approved uranium one one of the nine
along with Hillary Clinton and Maddow
can't ask him a single question about it
this is beyond media malpractice by the
way all you people at NBC News is proud
Lester Holt Matt Lauer you guys proud of
this megyn kelly are you proud of that
reporting Maddow has done a tremendous
disservice to you the American people
who deserve to know the truth in all of
this we're gonna have much more on the
liberal media bias in a few minutes but
first I want to tell you this we're also
learning new stunning information about
Hillary Clinton's campaign and the DNC
paying millions and millions of dollars
to finance what we now know and knew
then to be fake news anti Trump
propaganda in that dossier now this is
the same document that used current and
former Russian government sources to
make
all kinds of bizarre and salacious and
completely fabricated accusations about
Donald Trump now that means that Hillary
Clinton and the DNC played a direct role
in spreading propaganda Russian
propaganda misinformation and outright
lies to the American people to damage a
political opponent and try to alter the
outcome of an election sound familiar
that's the real Russia collusion now
unlike the lies and the conspiracy
theories that the media the Democrats
have been perpetuated perpetuating and
peddling for the last year against the
president in this case when it comes to
the fake news dossier we have concrete
facts incontrovertible evidence it is a
massive scandal that can no longer be
ignored now understand what we're saying
here Clinton and the DNC paid for
Russian lies in this campaign against
Donald Trump and the media ran wild with
those lies and one big question we have
tonight is why did James Comey want to
pay the guy behind the Stasi a
Christopher Steele and the Daily Caller
by the way there's one Democratic media
talking point today that was debunked
there that a Republican first hired
fusion GPS that was excuse me way before
Christopher Steele got involved this was
just basic opry search on an opponent
now Hillary Clinton's campaign they paid
for the dirt they paid for the lies they
paid for the propaganda on Trump and
we're also learning tonight that a
nonpartisan group called the campaign
Legal Center has filed a complaint with
the FEC saying that Hillary Clinton in
the DNC in fact broke the law by failing
to disclose payments connected to this
phony fake news Russian propaganda
dossier now Hillary Clinton in her
campaign they were more than happy to
help create and spread Russian
disinformation in this campaign against
Donald Trump and earlier today President
Trump reacted to this explosive scandal
and here's what he had to say on that I
think it's very sad what they've done
with this fake dossier
I understand they paid a tremendous
amount of money and Hillary Clinton
always denied it the Democrats always
denied it and now only because it's
going to come out in a court case they
said yes they did it they admitted it
and they were embarrassed by it but I
think it's a disgrace beyond a disgrace
the president also blasted Hillary
Clinton during an interview he was on
with our friend Lou Dobbs tonight on our
sister network the Fox Business Network
watch this
don't forget Hillary Clinton totally
denied this she didn't know anything she
knew nothing all of a sudden I found out
what I was amazed at it's almost six
million dollars that they paid and it's
totally discredited it's a total phony I
call it fake news it's disgraceful
that's the real collusion believe me
your thoughts there was no collusion on
my side I can tell you that now not only
is the dossier phony and by the way not
only fake news in this particular case
but Hillary Clinton and her liberal
cronies lied repeatedly about their
involvement and take a look for example
don't take my word for it look at the
tweets from two New York Times reporters
after the story broke last night Maggie
Haberman she tweeted quote folks
involved in funding this lied about it
and with sanctimony for a year Kenneth
Vogel he tweeted out quote when I tried
to report this story Clinton campaign
lawyer mark Elias he pushed back
vigorously saying you or your sources
are wrong now in the New York Times
starts literally calling Clinton's team
Liars you know it's bad Brian Fallon
Hillary Clinton's former spokesman he
wouldn't rule out the fact that Hillary
in fact may have known about the payment
for this dossier watch this tonight
you don't believe Hillary Clinton knew
about this either is that right oh I
don't know I know okay okay thank you
for clarifying yeah
shouldn't shouldn't she know shouldn't
you someone so high up in the campaign
be informed of this well I mean she may
have known but the degree of exactly
what she knew is as beyond my knowledge
they're all running as fast as they can
away from Hillary even the new DNC
chairman Tom Perez put out a statement
saying I wasn't personally involved but
never denied that his predecessors were
Democrats the media have been complicit
in this anti-trump dossier scandal
because they were quick to do the
Russians bidding and spread fake news
and work as an extension of the
Democratic Party's was basically media
operation remember this dossier claimed
Donald Trump in the Ritz in Moscow with
hookers urinating on his bed watch this
do you believe anything about that
dossier oh I think it should be taking a
look at
I think they should really read it
understand it analyze it and determine
what fact what may not be fact we
already know that the part about the
coverage that they have on him with sex
actions it's supposed to be true my
focus today is explore how many claims
within Steele's dossier are looking more
and more likely as though they are
accurate the dossier definitely seems
right on these points a quid pro quo
relationship seems to exist between the
Trump campaign and Putin's Russia there
is a lot in the dossier that is yet to
be proven but increasingly as we'll hear
throughout the day allegations are
checking out if famous dossier which is
getting a lot more credibility now that
it did well I think that's important
right that the dossier right which looks
sort of out there at first is getting
truer and truer and truer as facts come
out what I have learned I've heard about
the dossier it's about his involvement
with women it's about possibly
prostitutes that are involved and those
kinds of things
no it's about Hillary and the DNC paying
for Russian lies and you and the media
and you and politics in the Democratic
Party then spreading lies now keep in
mind this is the same media for over a
year they have been pushing this fake
and phony news of and black conspiracy
helicopter theories about so-called
Trump Russia collusion without any
evidence whatsoever last night only ABC
News reported the house opened a probe
into the uranium one deal only one
network during the evening newscasts now
there's also another major component to
the story we cannot discount the FBI the
Department of Justice have not been
cooperating with congressional
Republicans and their attempts to find
out more information about this fake
news
dossier and the group that is behind it
fusion GPS now the Speaker of the House
Paul Ryan welcome aboard mr. speaker
even he is now blasting what He is
calling attempts to stonewall this
massive corruption and investigation
it's really frustrating we've had these
document requests with the
administration in the FBI in particular
for a long time and they've been
stonewalling the the FBI and the Justice
Department needs to give Congress the
documents it's been requesting and they
need to do so immediately I can't tell
you how frustrating it is to learn
through the media you know information
that that Congress has been requesting
from the executive branch for a long
time
you could have watched this show we've
been saying for a while we've been
saying many times also the Attorney
General jeff Sessions and the Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosen seemed they
needed to get their heads out of the
sand start getting to the bottom of this
real Russian collusion the American
people have a right to know